Joining me as an evolutionary biologist,
formerly of Evergreen State University
who is now a professional professor in
exile,
Heather.
Hi and welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having today's professor
in exile.
I believe that is in your twitter bio.
It is.
I believe it is in your husband,
Bret Weinstein's twitter bio.
Yeah.
We generated it together.
Is that going to be the title of the Co
authored a book when the dust settles on
all of this stuff?
Oh,
I don't know.
I think both of us are both eager to
leave the evergreen story behind,
but still heartbroken that an
institution that we loved and still
believe in the educational model that it
offered and still believe in the
students who got great education was
there for many decades.
We would love to see it resurrected,
but it doesn't look like it's going to
happen.
Yeah.
All right,
so this is.
It's a little crazy to me that this is
the first time that we've met because
obviously our,
our circles have been sort of a closing
in on each other for for quite some
time.
So when,
when the whole evergreen thing happened
and I only want to spend a little bit of
time at the top talking about it and
then I want to do all sorts of
evolutionary biology stuff and the
other,
the other things that you're really
passionate about,
the story,
obviously it was more focused on Brett
and then he was sort of thrust into the
media and all that,
but this was a direct attack on you as
well in the end,
as you said,
the institution that you loved and all
that.
Can you just give me any sort of recap
or just pieces of it that maybe we don't
know that well or just your perspective
on what was happening there?
Well,
um,
as,
as briefly as I can,
leaving out many,
many relevant pieces,
we got a new president and the new
president very quickly got rid of a
provost who was going to get in his way
and spoke publicly about his desire to
turn evergreen into a social justice
college.
I was actually on the record early in
George Church's tenure at the point that
the protests broke out a year ago.
Now,
uh,
he had been president for about two
years and a year before that had broken
out in equity,
uh,
a desire to bring equity and inclusion
to the forefront,
which is,
which is cohorts.
It's dog whistles for the people on the
far left who are actually interested in
a reversal of power,
not an end to oppression,
but an actual reversal of historical
oppression.
Did you guys recognize those things as
dog whistles at the time?
Because as Brett said,
at the time he considers himself,
or at least at that time did consider
himself deeply progressive.
You just said to me right before we
started,
you still consider yourself progressive.
Yep.
So did you realize those buzzwords and
what they actually meant at the time?
Absolutely.
I mean,
Brett,
actually I was on sabbatical the year
most of the year before this breakout is
part of why I was disappeared from the
story I said as I went on to sabbatical,
but I will continue to read everything
you want to send out to these lists,
but I'm not engaging.
I'm doing my own work now.
So about a year,
actually a year to the day before the
protest broke out,
the first announcement of the new plan
came,
came live,
and then,
and there,
and for the next year,
Brett was,
I was a little bit a couple of other
people were a little bit standing up and
saying,
this doesn't smell right.
This,
this feels like this is actually about
something that we're not talking about.
And furthermore,
if we're actually interested in
improving the fate of various
demographic groups,
these processes are not going to be the
way to accomplish them.
So we were saying that Brett mostly was
saying that a few others of us were
saying it.
And um,
was there any,
um,
sort of understanding of that point of
view privately?
Yes.
Privately,
yes.
People were scared and when in fact,
when Brett used the phrase culture of
fear on campus,
what came back at him was you have to
prove that there's a culture of fear or
else there's not one.
And you know,
show me the people who aren't standing
up or else I will know that they don't
exist,
which is baffling.
It's,
it is obviously unimprovable an
unprovable statement to say there's a
culture of fear and I'm not going to out
the people who have come to me and told
me they're scared because I actually am
going to honor their privacy,
but if,
if everyone who would come to us
privately and said,
this is nuts and it's got to stop,
had stood up,
it would have been a totally different
outcome.
Well that's the culture of fear summed
up right there.
Right.
So,
um,
okay.
So without rehashing the whole thing,
can you just tell me a little,
just a little bit about sort of how your
life has changed throughout this and
sort of,
you know,
look,
you and Brett,
you guys did settle.
It wasn't for a ton of money,
at least in my humble estimation,
but I think you probably want it to just
put some of this behind you,
but you guys are professors in exile you
if you have kids and family and all that
stuff and just sort of sum up kind of
where you're at at the moment.
Yeah.
So when we had,
we'd been living in Olympia for 15
years.
Um,
the,
the college was an amazing place to
really do a deep dive in community with
students.
And so you know,
Brad and I had done one and I had done
several long study abroad trips and
Panama and in Ecuador with pretty large
groups of undergraduates taking them
through the Amazon.
They're galapagos.
We spent time in the field in Washington
state,
in the San Juans and eastern Washington.
You're took people places where not only
were we studying evolutionary biology
and animal behavior and field techniques
and Statistics and philosophy of
science,
but also coming to know each other such
that after,
after you break bread with people for
days and you play ultimate with them and
sit around a campfire,
you come to understand that when they
disagree with you,
it's not inherently coming from a place
of hatred or personal.
And so that trust that we were able to
create in our classrooms,
which both of us love to doing,
allowed us to effectively then rip the
intellectual rug out from under people
when they made claims that weren't
falsifiable or couldn't be.
You couldn't be justified once you
started to ask them what the assumptions
were there underlying their claims.
That was,
that was an amazing gift.
And I don't know that really almost any
other educational model out there allows
for that because it required the time to
build community with students,
which was,
which was wonderful.
So yes,
we lost two tenure track jobs along with
your health insurance and our retirement
plans and all of that and have two kids
still in school.
So that's alarming.
But some of what we were doing in the
classroom,
we have begun to do on larger stages.
And that is promising.
It seems clear that the world is
interested in hearing how to understand
systems from an evolutionary
perspective.
I knew that was true from the 25 or 50
students that I had doing the deep dive
for,
you know,
every quarter,
every year for years.
Uh,
it's not that surprising,
but it is heartening to see that that is
the response of many,
many people out there
in a weird way.
Does it almost feel right then that this
happened?
I mean,
I know it's kind of sucky and again with
the salaries in tenure track positions
and all that,
but that the message that you guys are
talking about seems so relevant right
now.
You guys are now doing more public
speaking gigs.
I'm,
I'm dragging bread onstage with me to do
stand up.
I mean all sorts of crazy things are
presenting themselves and then the sort
of the rise of this new alliance of
whether you want to call it intellectual
dark web or whatever you want to call it
at this point,
but there,
there is this sort of interesting crew
of people with a lot of different
feelings on a lot of different issues
with all sorts of different disciplines
coming together.
And maybe if you guys were still at
university in a traditional sense,
you wouldn't be able to be dealt in the
way that
you are now.
I think that's possible.
I think there is both a way in which
having gone through the looking glass,
having gone through the direct,
you know,
to borrow a phrase from the far left,
but the lived experience of actually
being at the center of a mob at the
center of riots and then watching as the
world,
the mainstream media and others tried to
do a public relations spin on it and
tell a totally different story to live
that and to watch the institution that
you love to become totally disloyal to
you and to watch many people whom you
respected,
um,
hide.
You can't unsee that it's valuable.
And the fact that we're sitting here
talking together and that many of us and
you know the intellectual,
dark web and in this,
in this bigger group are,
are speaking and saying actually the
culture of fear that is society wide is
real.
And so I'll say the first time I met my
students after the November 2016
election after trump was elected,
evergreen,
so very left place,
Olympia is a very left place.
Pretty much everyone on campus had that
glazed eyes.
Slack,
Jawed Lux that people in most
progressive enclaves will be familiar
with from that time,
from those few days,
right.
Myself included,
even though I was no hillary fan,
but I didn't see that outcome coming and
I certainly didn't vote for trump.
I,
um,
we got to class and my co faculty,
whom I admired greatly,
I just proceeded with her lecture on
horse evolution and I'm looking around
the classroom going,
no one here cares about horses the day
to day.
Um,
so she ended up at early and we had lab
a couple of hours later and before she
let them go,
I said,
hold on,
if anyone wants to stay,
this is no longer class,
but if anyone wants to stay,
I would be happy to lead a conversation
about what just happened,
what just happened to our country.
And about 40 of our 50 students stayed
and skip their lunch hour.
And then we went right to anatomy lab
that afternoon from,
from this conversation.
And what I said to them was,
do not for a minute believe that racists
and sexist elected trump.
Think about how many times you have had
to censor yourself on this campus when
you had an opinion that was even
slightly different from the accepted
Dogma and that conversation not only
brought life to the realm,
but afterwards I had several students
come up to me,
some of them in tears telling me stories
about one of them had lost a job on
campus for speaking in opinion that was
not accepted.
One of them had an another story of
another friend who lost a job.
Others talked about their self
censorship and I'm that and all of these
people again were four left.
Not that it should matter,
but these weren't even people who are
conservatives or who held conservative
views so that that is the larger culture
of fear that is hardly restricted to
evergreen,
but is society wide that we're,
that we're speaking about and that
people are responding to because in at
Google,
at starbucks,
in cubicles,
in campuses,
but far be on campuses across the
country and across the weird country is
at least this is a problem.
Well,
the irony too
me is that I think that all that I'm
doing is talking about these things
often with people who have a much better
pedigree than I do,
but by me talking about it,
it's giving room for other people to
talk about it and that's all that they
want.
Well,
you're,
you are also so
providing ways into the conversation.
I think so.
There are a lot of people when
confronted with.
You're not allowed to think that say,
Oh God,
I'm not actually sure how to respond.
I haven't.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't have the linguistic skills.
I don't have the analytics behind me.
I don't know what I'm supposed to say
here.
And so just listening to you and to Sam
Harris and the Jordan Peterson into
Brett and to Eric and to me and to many,
many others I believe begins to give
people a sense of not only is this
doable,
these are good,
reasonable,
smart people who are being respectful in
what they're saying,
but also it's not just tools.
It's actually like phrase it,
you know,
this is what you can say.
These are the things that sort of things
that you can say in response that are
still respectful and don't reject the
humanity of the person on the other
side,
but do reject the argument.
It's interesting.
It almost shows that
were you guys obviously were doing so
well at a university level.
That's exactly what's needed at a
societal level.
Now talking about the language,
the language to get these ideas across
is is so important.
I wonder is there a evolutionary
explanation for a little bit of what has
happened here with the left,
like the way they've sort of closed off
ranks and then purge everyone because
it's just as I sit here with you,
it's like the idea that you and Brett
wouldn't be enough of whatever it is
that they want is so bananas and yet it
is true.
So is there some way that you can
explain that coming from the discipline
you come from?
Well there's.
I think this is not going to be a
particularly deep point,
but it's,
it's basic ingroup outgroup dynamics and
we will always.
We will not get rid of of tribal
thinking.
We will not get rid of our sense of,
you know,
you and I are aligned,
right?
That's,
that's a good thing.
There's a way in which there's a kind of
tribalism there even though we just met
for the first time today and you know,
and we definitely have political
differences for sure.
Which we can talk about if we want.
Yeah,
right.
So,
but,
but that isn't the main thing.
Like we,
we're aligned and I,
you know,
I feel walking in here like you've got
my back and you've got my back and um,
I think people especially raised without
much experience with the physical world
and raised often in situations where
they're being given a number of
pharmaceuticals early on that are
disrupting development,
arrive at what should be the cusp of
adulthood and aren't sure how to
navigate,
aren't sure how to navigate the waters.
And so when told,
Oh,
if you just agree with everything,
if you just become an idea log and go in
lock step with us,
you can be with us.
So you know,
identity politics is appealing because
it provides an instant in group if you
will only subjugate yourself and your
identity.
Politics on this side,
b gets it.
Anti politics on this side of course,
because anyone who shows up here and is
told no,
you don't have enough of what the
progressive stack tells us you made,
either you can totally subjugate
yourself or go over there and we'll of
course we're going to get a rise over
here and back and forth
when people criticize us,
whoever this is for not focusing on that
identity politics enough,
the one that,
the secondary one that you're talking
about here,
which is the identity politics of the
right,
which is either which is based in actual
racism or,
or you know,
there's a white ethno state or ideas
that are.
So the antithesis of the American
experiment is to me they're,
they're ridiculous and have no real real
world traction.
It's almost like we've this boogeyman
because we need it long since been
displayed.
No,
no.
Almost no one thinks that way anymore.
Sorry.
No.
Well,
so what's your,
what's your best argument against that?
When people say,
well,
you're not focusing on that enough
because because everyone wants
everything to be equal all the time.
If you're focusing on the identity
politics of the left,
which clearly many of us see as.
I mean,
I truly see it.
I've been saying,
listen,
I really believe this.
I view it as the greatest existential
threat to western democracy that there
is.
I believe that if there's something that
would cause us to be on the streets like
killing each other,
I think it's that we're.
We'll have broken off and all of the
commonalities will will disappear,
but what?
What do you think is the best argument
for what?
You're not focusing on that one enough
because I see that a lot now,
right?
I think.
I think two things.
One,
it's not as big a group,
right?
The,
the white nationalists,
the extent that they exist and they do
are better armed by and large than than
the far left,
but numerically they just don't exist in
the same numbers and they don't have the
kind of play.
They don't have the kind of cultural
reach that the far left does.
And so that's the second.
Well,
I guess there's three points.
A secondary point then is everyone can
walk white nationalists that is
completely acceptable and in fact
demanded that you do when those sorts of
ideas come up in conversation.
Whereas the stuff on the far left,
increasingly it is demanded that you
not.
So there is,
that's the key right there.
So like we are saying,
no,
actually we must,
we must disagree with this just as much
as we should.
Just as much as culturally we now know
it's a norm to disagree with what's on
the right we,
the far right.
It should become a cultural norm to
disagree with frankly the cryptic racism
and sexism and everything else that's
happening on the far left.
It is,
it comes packaged as if it's anti
racist,
anti sexist and all,
it's just,
it's racist and sexist against the other
group.
It's a flipping of the tables of
oppression.
So I would say the third point is,
for me anyway,
as someone who has been on the left my
whole life,
uh,
this has changed,
this experience is going through the
looking glass in the last year has not
changed my values,
but it has changed what I understand
about how people are using language to
make other people out to be things
they're not.
So,
you know,
I no longer believe in a massive
outright for instance.
Right.
Um,
and you know,
the boogeyman that are out there that
you're not supposed to do things like
talk to Fox News.
Sorry.
No,
actually we should all be exposing
ourselves to,
to the media across the entire range.
And for me on the left,
it's actually my job much more so than
to go after people who I have nothing in
common with,
to go after the people who claim to have
values that are similar to mine.
But I see that they are actually
achieving goals that are different.
Yeah.
And that's why I love this conversation
and don't get tired of it because we're
all in on it at different levels.
We all have different realizations at
different times along the timeline and
it's like for me,
that's where I free for two years.
I kept saying I'm of the left and that's
why I want to fix this.
I don't think realistically anymore I
can honestly say that I think I have
more in common certainly with
Libertarians and I find it.
I find an intellectual openness with
conservatives that I just don't find
anymore.
On this other side,
and I know there's.
Again,
I know there's some people you just
spoke at Heterodox,
a Heterodox,
Jonathan hates been on the show.
I think he's doing wonderful work.
There's obviously people like Brett and
like Eric and and Steven pinker and
plenty and Sam and plenty of other that
exists still as sort of a same left,
but I see that just being whittled and
whittled and whittled away and that
doesn't mean that it's not worth taking
it.
Maybe it means it's the most worthy
fight,
but I just see it as like an
increasingly untenable position to hold.
I think.
I think there are actually many,
many,
many people out there who are not,
who don't have public platforms,
who are waiting,
who've been waiting for this,
who are watching your.
Most of these people would consider the
songs themselves Democrats,
as I always did.
I don't,
I don't want to identify as a Democrat
anymore given what they know,
stand for a.
But most I think that and this,
you know,
as evidenced by my inbox.
So it's anecdotal,
but it's a lot of anecdotes and you
know,
and also my twitter feed a that there
are a massive number of people out there
who are on the left who have values on
the left and who find no one out there
who was making sense except now.
Yeah.
And it,
it has taken.
It has taken this to,
you have this fever pitch that we have
arrived at a for a number of people.
I really think and like I said,
you know Google starbucks,
but it's not just those big stories.
There are people writing to me and to
Brett from just average workplaces
saying,
I'm in fear for my job because I cannot
speak anything that doesn't fit the
dogma.
We just hired an equity advisor.
We just hired an inclusion advisor and
it's,
and it's hateful.
It's hateful rhetoric that we are being
told to adopt.
This is what's happening across
corporate America now.
Of course most Americans are not going
to appreciate that.
Yeah.
It's like it existed at the universities
for a long time and finally it started
bubbling out of there and those kids
took those ideas and started entering
the workforce.
That's why it's so weird.
You know,
people say you're all,
you're focusing on college students too
much and it's like,
do realize they get out of college
usually,
right.
If they're supposed to.
So tell me a little bit more about sort
of what you're doing now.
I know you just spoke at Heterodox and
uh,
or let's start.
Let's start with that
heterodox.
Yeah.
Well,
the Heterodox Academy's first
conference,
uh,
they and fire are really at the
forefront institutionally of defending
viewpoint diversity on campuses.
A fire from sort of more of a legal
perspective and Heterodox at the faculty
administrative perspective and it was
point.
It was an intense conferences.
The only conference I've ever been to
where I thought they should have been
longer.
I wanted to go longer.
It was a daisy.
All academics in the audience as well,
or do they open that up?
I think.
I think there were probably
non-academics there.
I know that there were a lot of
journalists there.
Uh,
and most everyone I met were students or
faculty or Admin or journalists.
So I don't know.
I don't know what the,
what the entry rules were,
but you know,
the panels were as,
as Jonathan Heit at the end of the day,
I,
Jonathan Count only three people who are
on the panels of I guess 28 people who
might be conservative.
So he himself pointed out,
you know,
we're striving for viewpoint diversity,
but the fact is it's an uphill battle,
you know,
we're not going to get just,
just like we shouldn't expect a 50 slash
50 sex ratio amongst software software
engineers between men and women were
we're not going to get a 50 slash 50
ratio of liberals and conservatives on
college campuses.
It's not necessarily the kind of work
that conservatives flocked to in the
same numbers as liberals do.
So I think we need to be careful about
imagining what,
what equity would look like as in all of
these arguments.
At an ideal level,
why would it be that conservatives would
be less inclined to be doing academics?
I guess it depends on what our
definition of conservative is.
One of stereotype that comes to mind
that I may regret saying is that a
liberal types take some odd pride and
not caring about making a good living,
making good money in faculty positions
tend to tend to fit that right?
Certainly Evergreen did.
Um,
so,
you know,
if you,
if what if one of your primary goals is
not only to make a good living for
yourself,
but potentially to leap out of the
living you're making and you know,
really hit it big,
you're unlikely to do that in academia.
Uh,
so there's a,
there's a sort of a risk aversion.
I think I'm to the prospect of making it
big financially that academics tend to
have that maybe,
maybe conservatives would be less likely
to,
to go that way.
Do you think it could also be the
conservatives were just self selecting
out,
like they realized the hostile
atmosphere.
So they were just like,
why would I do this?
Absolutely.
That is one of the explanations for
sure.
And um,
you know,
certainly in some fields,
an engineered the,
the less human focus,
the field,
the more conservatives there are,
we know this.
So in engineering,
for instance,
in the physical sciences,
mostly people don't speak their politics
on college campuses if they are on the
right because they're not welcome there.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but those fields do have higher
representations of conservatives than
liberals.
But most of the social sciences and
humanities,
uh,
we're all always tended liberal but are
even more so,
I don't remember the numbers off the top
of my head,
but even more so now than they ever have
been.
And that's a problem to have,
you know,
take,
you have to have a field that is trying
to understand the nature of humans,
any of the social sciences,
psychology or anthropology or sociology
to be entirely limited to people on the
left side of the political spectrum.
Maybe you're missing something in your
explanation of what humans are if you
don't have anyone who's willing to speak
to a different political position.
So when I've talked
to Jordan Peterson,
who you referenced and my friend Peter,
but goes in and a couple other people
who are professors,
um,
you probably know Pete,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
I think a lot of their argument is based
around that,
you know,
gender studies and these sort of,
these sort of new fueled basically have
a completely separate set of standards
that have been.
It had virtually nothing to do with any
of the standards that you as an
evolutionary biologist had to,
had to and have to prescribe to,
to do your work.
Is that really the crux of it?
Sort of at the institutional level at
schools
I,
that is at least one of the first site
that,
that I have seen as well,
that there are many new fields,
many of which end in the word studies,
uh,
like gender studies that are there.
They're made up.
They are based in postmodernism and not
just,
not just postmodernism because at its
base originally there,
there's some stuff of value there,
believe it or not,
but the new manifestations in critical
theory and such are,
are basically free of any fact checking
apparatus.
So they are,
they are anti science,
anti enlightenment,
and,
and they're quite willing to say things
like reason is a tool.
Patriarchy.
This is the new one.
This sort of popping up in the last six
months.
Right?
And I mean,
you,
you just have to know you're dealing
with people who are not going to be
playing in good faith and willing to
have an.
Actually,
you know,
viable argument at the point that they
say that,
uh,
so it's,
that there has been capture,
you know,
pretty pretty solid capture and a few of
the more traditional fields.
I'm not entirely,
in fact,
I met several people at Heterodox,
um,
who are sociologists who are fighting
this from within,
but sociology is one of the captured
fields,
anthropology,
geography and cultural anthropology in
particular,
so that the fact that it is that there
are fields that students can go into and
basically never be exposed to the idea
of you're going to generate as many
possible explanations for the thing that
you've observed as possible.
We're going to do hypothesis generation
first and then we're going to try to
figure out what would have to be true if
any,
if each of those individual hypotheses
were true and then we're going to try to
figure out how to test between them.
That's the scientific method and it's
inefficient.
It sometimes gets things wrong,
but it is the only tool we have to over
time get to a better and better
understanding of the universe.
And there's,
there's no,
there's no method over in gender
studies.
Yeah.
So how have you seen that way of
thinking leak into the harder sciences
because this seems to be the next
frontier.
Yeah.
Um,
there are,
there are some schools now that when
positions come open in,
um,
in science disciplines.
So for most schools,
this wasn't sure at Evergreen,
but at most schools through the hiring
apparatus within,
uh,
within department.
So you know,
someone in physics retires and physics
gets to the society,
the Physics Faculty and Department Chair
and such get to decide what kind of
physicists they're going to hire next.
Somehow increasingly science educators
are being as being hired rather than
scientists themselves.
And science educator is a code word for
people coming out of Ed schools and
education schools have,
have this pathogen very,
very badly.
So I'm science educators being hired
into positions that should have been
scientists means that now you have a
weakening of scientific voice and
scientific method in science
departments.
You have A.
I mean even was it just recently nature,
I think published one of the two big
science journals published.
I don't know if it was a letter or an
article arguing that one of the primary
things that science needs to be focusing
on is increasing diversity.
So you have two problems with this.
What are your measures of diversity?
It's the stuff that you can see on first
pass.
This is immutable characteristics and
has nothing to do with actually all the
other kinds of diversity that are
interesting and that you know and that
we can change things like political
belief and you know,
some things that we can't change,
but things like being on the autism
spectrum or you know,
even like,
you know,
colorblindness or dyslexia or lefthand
and is all of which provide your brain
without us ever being conscious of it.
Some different way of approaching the
world and that kind of diversity in a
group of people,
ads,
actual intrigue and nuanced to
conversations.
And then I'm a lefty with a little
dyslexia.
Actually.
I'm a lefty too.
Yep.
So,
you know,
lefty is like,
like many other members of these groups
with.
I happened to happen at other lefty one
because I've,
I've done some research on it.
Lefties are overrepresented at,
you know,
in the National Academy of Sciences and
a mental institution.
You've got this really big spread.
Well now I can see that there's really
two options for your future.
That's right.
Alright,
let's talk about consciousness a little
bit.
I just had Sam Harrison,
we,
we've talked about it quite extensively.
I think you have some thoughts on
consciousness,
the nature of consciousness.
Indeed.
Yeah.
I mean it's probably do this right.
We would need to agree on a definition
that I'm not sure that that's any
definition that we choose will
immediately antagonized some amount of
your audience.
This is like defining,
defining truth,
which seems to be tough these days.
Yes,
exactly.
Um,
so maybe,
maybe rather than that,
um,
are humans the only conscious beings on
this planet?
I don't think so,
but we are the most conscious.
We are the most fully conscious and we
have better access to our own
consciousness obviously.
Then we have access to the consciousness
of say,
dolphins or elephants or other apes or
maybe a wolves.
Any of these long lived social organisms
with long childhoods and generational
overlap who lived sometimes with three
generations together at a time,
so there's transmission of cultural
information,
organisms that have theory of mind and
can imagine can put themselves in the
other individual's position and think,
what do they think is going on right
now?
Even though I understand that that's a
different thing than what I think is
going on right now,
which we now know that certain monkeys
and apes exactly do that.
Yes,
theory of mind.
There's a beautiful book called Baboon
Metaphysics by the husband and wife,
team Chaney and Seyfarth that basically
explores theory of mind and baboons.
Uh,
and,
you know,
it's not the only one.
They're,
they're not the only spaces,
but,
you know,
how do we as humans find our
consciousness best?
You know,
there,
there are ways that we can hack into
what is sometimes been called flow
states or um,
you know,
that's,
that's the most common one.
But yeah,
we can do so through,
well through deep conversation,
um,
through meditation,
through music,
some sometimes through producing it,
but sometimes through experiencing,
especially live music,
dance for some people,
Hallucinogens,
sex,
sport,
you know,
intense physical or physiological or
emotional experience in which we are
just moving with others usually.
And you know,
there are those of us like myself,
you know,
very strong introvert who will find so
my deepest flow states,
you know,
access to consciousness alone,
you're alone in the Amazon when I could
sit and watch monkeys and write that for
me.
That's one of them.
But sport is also.
So when I talked about this with Sam,
the way he was defining it,
which I think is sort of similar to what
you're saying here,
it strikes me as just like an extreme
ability to maintain present in the
moment that that really sort of when a
basketball player.
So if we use the sport analogy,
like a basketball player when they're in
the zone,
you know,
and Jordan scores 20 points in five
minutes and he just,
he,
he said,
well,
everything I threw up just went in like
that.
They hit that level of consciousness or
for you to be outside enough out of
yourself to be able to write in that
perfect moment or,
or whatever it is that it.
Oh,
it always seems about present more than
anything else.
To me,
there is a kind of,
um,
time stopping both time stopping and
disappearing on you at the same time,
which I think is part of why entheogenic
hallucinogens can,
can capture that as well because their
sense of time just disappearing on you
is,
is remarkable.
Um,
so you,
you both don't care about time and time
passes usually in ways that seemed
quicker than you were expecting them to,
uh,
with,
with a sport or um,
or right meditation that,
yeah,
that's not one that I do.
But um,
you know,
Sam has a lot to say about that.
Of course.
Um,
yeah,
I remember when I was doing mushrooms at
least sort of in college age,
somewhat consistently,
maybe every six months or something.
I would always want the clocks to be
covered.
Yes.
Because I hated the numbers are no good.
I did.
I definitely did one trip like five
hours in a mirror,
forget that,
but I always wanted the clocks to be
covered because the idea that time was
passing while I was in this state was,
was very scary to me.
Yeah,
that's scary.
Or just I just wanted nothing to do with
it.
I guess maybe it doesn't matter what
that distinction is,
you know,
scary or just not interested.
Right.
But,
um,
so it's,
it's very different than the kinds of
consciousness enhancing activities that
we can engage in,
including hallucinogens are very
different if you're inside in a room
like this where you have no access to
what is going on climate illogically or
weather-wise outside as opposed to if
you,
if you are out and you can watch as the
sunsets and as the moon comes up and you
can think again,
oh,
right,
it's a,
it's a waxing moon.
It'll be full in four days and um,
or you know,
or you're at a coast and you can watch
the tides and think about the shifting
time.
So for me,
thinking about time that is clearly
being brought as clearly being revealed
by the planet we're on as opposed to
coming at me through a clock is more
meaningful and I'm willing,
I'm willing to think about time in that
way,
but definitely not through clocks when
I'm,
when I'm writing hallucinogen sport,
any of that.
Right.
And yet we have all of these devices now
that our men our time that are meant to
take our attention that are literally
designed this way.
Do you sense we're on so that there's
actually a digital assault on
consciousness because maybe that really
does explain so many of the other
problems we're having in society right
now.
It's,
it's one of the key pieces for sure.
And I think that phrase is brilliant at
digital assault on consciousness.
This is something.
I'm Tristan Harris who I don't know,
but I've got them on the show.
Yeah.
Talks talks about a lot and you know,
he,
he has been,
he has been ringing the alarm bell for
years about the algorithms that are
being put into our devices that are,
that are creating addicts out of us.
But more broadly,
you know,
the digital assault on consciousness is,
there's not,
there is,
it's increasingly hard to find a space
where you're just actually free and
clear.
And this is,
you know,
this is part of what I do for myself and
what I used to do for my students was
take them to places,
not only that we're remote and where
they could explore nature,
but where there was no cell signal where
there was no internet.
So you know,
the deepest part of the Amazon that I
took students to.
There's just,
there's no email,
there's no internet,
there's no Wifi.
We are a plane ride over the Andes and
then a boat ride and then a truck ride
and then another five hours down,
a tributary of the Amazon to a place
with no roads,
no airstrips,
nothing.
And boy does time feel different and you
know,
you're sleeping in little cabins that
are screened.
And so you wake up when the insects and
the birds and the monkeys wake up and
they start talking at you.
They're not talking to you the document
themselves,
but you getting a sense of the rhythms
of the planet that we're on can return
people,
I think to a real sense of self and also
to a sense of what they value,
what their passions are.
And this is a big thing I think is
missing in many of the.
To return to what we were talking about
earlier.
You know,
the,
the far left activists,
the control left mostly I think lack
another passion.
And I've said before I,
you know,
the prediction I would make is that you
have very few rock climbers or scares
among the radical left activists.
People who have something that they can
engage in that frees them from time and
devices from,
from a response to time.
I need to be here then,
or this my thing just pinged me.
I need to look at it,
uh,
are better able to center themselves to
find their own consciousness and
discover who,
who they are and what they want to be in
the world.
What does that say about the self?
Do you think?
To me,
there's something there about like if
you really believe in the self and your
and the individually and your ability to
overcome things,
you don't need all of these external
processes to help define the world
because you're sort of defining it
yourself.
I,
I agree and I think I do think for me
self sufficiency is one of my highest
values personally and I have a.
I have a very hard time understanding
anyone who says,
Oh,
if you leave me on my own,
I wouldn't know what to do.
Like I,
I just,
I just don't get this.
I don't get why you would.
Maybe it's a lefty thing.
I'd be fine.
I'm like,
what?
Why would.
Why would you broadcast to the world
that you would be helpless?
This doesn't make any sense to me,
but you know,
there,
there are plenty of situations where I
wouldn't know what to do and I would
know what to do in situations that most
people wouldn't just because of where
I've traveled and where I've lived,
but the idea that self sufficiency
require the idea that you want to be
self sufficient requires a concept of
self,
I think is is important here.
Yeah.
Maybe just maybe that.
Yeah,
and if you give that up,
well then boy,
you're giving up a lot.
You give up so much.
And the devices as,
as heroin,
as Tristan Harris has argued,
are addicting us.
It's no accident.
We're,
you know,
we,
we should not view ourselves actually as
weak.
We,
when we get addicted to the things we
should wean ourselves.
We should as much as possible to provide
ourselves zones,
periods of time when we have no access
to those things.
And so we are actually free and clear to
let our minds do what they will because
when,
when we,
when they have access to our brands,
they are designed to addict us.
So using,
using the discipline that you're an
expert in,
is it possible that we're in a unique
position right now because of technology
that our brains are actually evolving
now evolving or I guess devolving
depending on which way you look at it at
an extraordinarily high pace or,
or something like that,
you know,
the,
the rate of change across almost every
sector in the economy and in human
experience right now is higher than it's
ever been.
Could you say that about any moment in
history maybe,
but the rate of change itself is
changing as well.
So that's the important distinction,
right?
Um,
and what is going on with technology is
completely untested.
And so this is,
this is a place where,
you know,
why,
why am I so certain that I'm still on
the left,
even though most of the people who say
they're on the left publicly,
I don't have any interest in continuing
to talk to them because they don't seem
to be making any sense.
I look at systems that are involved,
that are,
that are in stable state because they've
evolved over millions,
tens of millions,
hundreds of millions of years.
And my instinct is don't mess with that
until you really,
really understand what you're doing.
And so for instance,
I,
unlike many scientists and not feeding
my children gmos,
I give them and myself organic food and
when we meet,
which we do a lot of,
I want that meat to have been fed the
grass,
if it's the food of its ancestors,
what or what exactly is the harm?
We now know a little bit of this but 20
years ago if you would ask me what's the
harm and feeding cows grants.
So I have no idea,
but I know that messing with a system
that was working is more likely to
interfere with something in that animal
then not why,
you know,
why would you mess if you could not,
and of course their economic reasons to
mess.
But um,
the,
don't mess with systems that are working
until you really have a solid
understanding of what the,
what the effects are going to be.
The use of the precautionary principle
pretty widely is what puts me pretty far
on the left,
but systems that we've created that are
evolutionary,
but people don't know that we need to
regulate in order to get them under
control because nuclear energy isn't
gonna regulate itself and habitat loss
throughout most of the world is not
going to regulate itself.
So there are some problems that we've
created and that are bigger than
individuals can do anything about.
And you know,
that's why I'm not a libertarian.
Yeah.
Right.
And this is.
This is where I think we have.
Oh,
I get it.
Like I don't know that if you just leave
everybody to do whatever the hell they
want all the time,
that everybody isn't going to be doing
all sorts of awful things.
I think generally the market does fix
some of that,
but I get what you're saying.
Like these systems are I suppose often
precarious in nature too,
to the point where anything can be
tilted one way or the other and then
we've got bigger problems.
Right?
So how do we,
how do we fix some of this stuff?
How do we,
how do we actually scale this back?
I mean,
I get it,
you know,
most of my artists will get.
Okay,
well we have to keep talking about it.
Should we have to wake more people up?
Sure.
But what can you do using the knowledge
you have in the study you've done?
I have less.
I have less insight right now at least
to answer in this amount of time for the
adult systems.
Um,
but I think I have a fair amount of
clarity on what we should do,
should be doing with children and with
parenting.
We're really,
really not doing a,
which is,
when you say the adult systems,
you mean like economic system?
Well,
it's just like,
and,
and more specifically,
how do you get adults who were already
who they are to behave differently.
Um,
it's,
it's less clear to me what we can do and
so we'll show them for the purpose of,
and you know,
and the CIS.
Yes.
Also also,
it's true that I have,
um,
that I'm not going to wade into,
for instance,
what we should do a better economic
system here.
Now with you,
I might do it later,
but yeah,
um,
but with regard to,
for instance,
you know,
most,
most people I think have never thought
about what childhood is and if you don't
have children yourself and you're an
adult,
okay,
maybe you don't have to.
Maybe it doesn't matter.
Like maybe it just doesn't matter to
you,
but if you're a parent,
you need to think about why it is that
we have literally the longest childhood
relative to lifespan of any organism on
the planet.
This is a feature.
This is a way for us to learn how to
become humans.
We are not,
and this is,
this is a point that Brett has made very
often.
We're not blank slates,
but we are the blanket slates of any
organisms on the planet.
We,
we are more software than hardware.
And so what we're doing for these first,
I don't know,
11 to 25 years of our lives right now
into the forties.
I think it depends,
but depending on culture,
you know,
when do you start calling yourself an
adult in the room?
That's what we're doing is learning how
to be human.
And we're learning how to be human by
direct exposure.
We're supposed to be learning how to be
human through instruction,
direct instruction by our parents,
through observing our parents,
through observing our siblings,
through interacting with,
including fighting with our siblings and
having them smack us down both sometimes
literally,
but definitely metaphorically when we do
stupid things.
And um,
better yet,
if our parents have lots of adult
friends around and they have lots of
kids and there's a whole mess of
humanity that we are learning from.
And then we're also in that very long
developmental period supposed to be
learning from direct physical experience
of the world.
So the example I like to go to here is,
um,
you know,
the,
the roadrunner cartoons when Wiley
Coyote scoots is way off a cliff and he
doesn't fall until he realizes there's
nothing below him.
It's funny,
right?
Like it's really funny.
But of course it's funny because we know
the gravity doesn't really work that
way.
Increasingly.
I suspect that a lot of kids and now
into the Ihn and,
and some of the younger millennials kind
of art,
sure.
Like they were protected so much by
their helicopter parents and they were
behind screens rather than having real
experience and to the extent that they
played sport,
it was totally regulated and overseen by
adults and they didn't have any free
time to go and get themselves into
trouble and maybe even like burn
something down or hurt themselves or
break an arm or whatever it is and learn
from it that they arrive at the cusp of
what should have been adulthood.
Totally unclear on what that supposed to
mean.
Does this absolutely to you because as
I'm hearing you say that this is the
bell going off in my head,
man,
I've been on tour where Peterson for the
last six weeks.
Everything that you just said there is
basically what he is saying.
He is trying to.
I sent that what he's trying to do at
the most personal level.
Yeah.
He talks about society as a whole,
but at the most personal level he's
trying to retool young people.
It's not even retool.
He's trying to give them the tools in
the first place that they clearly should
have gotten before.
Yeah,
so that's what's so fascinating to me
because it's like,
how did this happen?
Right?
How did,
how did this happen?
And we can point to,
we can point to pharmaceuticals being
given to kids to make boys less boy
like,
and to some degree to make girls less
girl like,
you know,
give great,
let's give speed to boys.
So they'll sit and face forward and
learn what.
So they'll calm down,
calm down and not do rough and tumble
play.
And I mean that's insane.
And at the same time,
let's give antianxiety meds to girls and
SSR rise.
And um,
and you know,
just just the model of schooling is
ridiculous.
You know,
we have,
we have schools that have gotten rid of
recess because recess is dangerous and
everyone who's ever been in school,
even if like me,
you happen to have been a good fit for
the model of schools that you were in,
which I think is pretty rare actually
knows that you also need to have time to
get out there and play and move your
body and experience it and not have it
being overseen by some adult who's
decided in advance what isn't,
is not safe for you to experience.
So,
you know,
one of the things I used to say to my
students in advance,
we did a lot of team building,
like actual team building and planning
with them in advance that these long
study abroad trips,
we would have spent weeks together on
campus in advance of going on these
trips.
Um,
but what I wanted to do before we left
was established with them.
What's your relationship with risk?
How do you,
how do you view yourself,
your relationship with the risk?
And we would do this in round lake and I
would answer the question to,
you know,
I would say to them,
actually I happen to love risk.
I will,
I'm the leader on this trip,
but I will keep all of you safe.
But then I'm going to go do things like
I am going to walk alone in the forest a
lot and do things because it happens to
be one of the ways that I find my
consciousness that I,
that I find my truest self and I don't
expect any of you to do that also.
But you need to be comfortable with the
fact that your leader is going to be
doing that sort of thing.
And one of the other things that we
would talk about was,
you know,
what's your relationship with comfort?
You're going to be uncomfortable.
You don't have to,
you know,
just because you can say in advance
you're okay with the bugs and the mud
and the not having a phone doesn't mean
you actually will be when you're faced
with it.
But maybe most important is we are going
to leave ourselves open to serendipity.
I cannot tell you everything that we're
going to do or learn on this trip.
If I could,
what would be the point of going we're
going to go and some interesting things
are going to happen.
I've,
I've had a couple of near death
experiences on these trips.
I didn't want them.
My didn't know and you know,
I was,
I was a learning experience where there
is a learning experience and frankly on
the most recent one on a,
on a boat in the galapagos with eight
students in which the only thing that
didn't survive was the boat,
but it was,
it was really touch and go.
I mean,
I really did almost die.
Those eight students and I are friends
for life.
Right?
You know,
there's,
there's some of them that I'm not an
active contact with,
but I,
I know where they are and that you know,
that bonds you and no,
I'm not going to pitch a trip with
Andrew might die.
That's not what the goal is,
but the idea that it could happen and
you should have the tools on board,
the physical tools,
psychological tools,
the emotional tools,
the intellectual tools to figure out in
real time as your boat is being flipped
by a 15 foot wave and now you're trapped
under it.
What do you do with that?
A uniquely Evergreen type of teaching?
Was that something that you and Brett
really,
that was a unique name,
their knee kind of teaching and then
this last trip,
Brett was there with me as well.
There was,
there was a way in which I think what
we,
what I said about childhood,
which I,
you know,
my interest originally in evolution was
about the evolution of parental care and
territoriality and social systems and
sexual selection and long before I ever
had kids myself long before I wanted
kids,
but I thought,
you know,
one sprint and I did have kids and I'm
watching these amazing creatures began
to grow up.
Okay,
let's think then about what,
what is the best way to do this?
And we could put them a little boxes and
make absolutely sure that they survive
till the age of 18 and then we open up
the boxes and we let them out and they
have basically no chance of being adults
or even of knowing how to be adults or
we could expose them to ever greater
risk having first made absolutely sure
that they know that they are loved and
that we have their backs and that we
will do anything to come in and get them
and to protect them if we can,
but that they are going to start going
out into the world pretty early,
you know,
biking it too.
And you know,
we took him to the Amazon at seven and
nine the first time.
And you know,
something could have gone wrong and I
don't know.
I've known parents who lost kids and I
don't know how you survive that,
but you need to be willing to take risks
such that when your kids do hit 18 or 20
or whatever,
you know that they're actually already
on their way to being adults.
And that is gonna require backing off
and letting them do some of their
learning on their own and knowing that
that's going to result in some harm
coming to them and it's going to be
physical harm,
it's going to be psychological harm,
it's going to be intellectual harm,
but frankly the lack of any kind of harm
that a lot of kids are experiencing is
part of why they're now saying speeches,
violence,
right?
I mean that's,
that's part of how we get there.
If some of this,
an extension of the success of the West
in a way.
Because if you take the set of kids who
however old they are,
let's say we go from.
Although now there's a lot of studies
that are showing that young,
the generation younger than millennials
is actually leaning more conservative.
But let's say we take 16 to 30 roughly.
So generation y ish that you see that
most of their parents were baby boomers
who were the most successful,
at least financially generation ever.
Most of the baby boomers,
parents all went to war and you know,
lived through depression and all sorts
of.
But that because the baby boomer is
basically where the biggest middle class
and because there was such upward
mobility,
they had it so well,
they kind of got their eye off the ball,
started focusing on things that didn't
matter as much,
protecting kids from things that a kid
would have used to have to have done.
And that is sort of what led us here.
So it's almost like an economic backing
for what ended up happening
psychologically.
Yeah,
I think.
I think that's apt.
You know,
there are so many things feeding into
this and yes,
the wealth of America Post World War
Two,
uh,
and the fact that those are most of the
parents of the generation that seems the
most confused,
I think definitely there's a causal link
there.
Yeah.
And then you toss in the Internet and
you toss on the Internet,
right?
Um,
which,
you know,
we can't go back obviously,
uh,
but,
but we need to understand that it's an
evolutionary system and then it's going
to run away from us and that we are all
prone to be addicted to dopamine hits.
We were going to the quick,
the quick likes rather than,
you know,
even even.
Okay.
So take internet out of the picture for
a moment if you don't know what you do
for physical activity.
I bike you play basketball.
Okay.
So maybe with basketball it's going to
be different for me.
I liked video games too.
Is that better?
I,
no,
that's probably the opposite.
Probably the opposite.
So I used to play a lot of ultimate
frisbee and you could.
Oh,
like anytime there was a pickup game,
like I,
I,
I'm,
I'm there.
I was playing five,
six times a week for awhile and then I
ruptured my Achilles tendon playing on
an Oregon beach with students a few
years ago.
I'm not doing that anymore.
Um,
but biking,
which I love and I find meditative.
I have a very hard time convincing
myself to get on my bike even though
while I'm doing it,
I love it.
And after I do it,
I feel better and I'm more productive
and a more creative and I just am more
in love with life,
but it's a pain in the ass and it's a
little bit physically uncomfortable.
And you know,
all of these things are true.
We,
we prioritize the,
the pleasure of now over even something
that for me,
I know not,
it's not even that I'm going to feel
better after I did it.
I actually love the activity itself.
But getting over that sort of activation
energy to do the thing.
And I suspect that sport,
like actual team sports is a little bit
different,
a little different.
Like you're ready to go,
you're ready to go.
Like,
oh,
people are there,
I'm ready.
I'm like,
let's go to the gym.
I would like into that.
Like I know that when I work out I like
doing it and I feel great after it.
But it's like,
oh,
I got to get in my car.
I got to drive over there.
I got a bark and blah blah blah.
It feels like a chore.
Yeah,
but you yet,
you know,
it's good.
And yet,
so we're always fighting our nature sort
of we are now.
Exactly.
We're always fighting her nature and it
shouldn't surprise us that we're going
to need to fight our nature with regard
to responding to the Internet and
responding to,
especially especially the little
computers we carry around in our pockets
and you know,
learning to restrict our access to those
training ourselves to restrict their
access to those.
And I think anyone with the ability to
train themselves to meditate or to do
anything on a regular basis should,
should be able to train themselves that
same way with regard to devices.
All right,
well we've done about an hour here and I
was going to demand that you come back
because I know,
I know we can do way more of this
unfortunate just because my schedule is
so nuts at the moment.
We have to kind of stop.
But can you give me one more thing that
you're just really excited about right
now that you've been thinking about or
working on or anything else that's
really just giving you a little bit,
uh,
a little bit of juice at the moment
while you're in this interesting space
for yourself?
No.
Um,
there are a number of things I guess.
there's a,
there's a piece I wrote a number of
years ago that is supposed to be out in
the literary magazine just about now,
ish about,
haven't been mugged at knife point and
Quito at one of these on one of these
study abroad trips which prompt and I
was with three students.
Is Quito the capital of Ecuador.
Oh,
okay.
So it was,
it was the very,
it was before the first day of one of my
six week study abroad trips.
So 20 students just made.
Brent wasn't there on this one.
Um,
and the experience in which,
you know,
we'd been,
we'd been to get the three students that
I have been together all day.
We come to the top of the stairs and
suddenly two guys with with knives run
around the corner and pin me and my
female student up against a wall and do
this sort of knife dance in front of us
and then relieve.
I didn't have anything on me because I
know how to walk around Latin American
cities and one of my students didn't,
but two of my students had all of their
stuff taken off of them,
including this really nice dslr that
Michelle and my student had and they run
off and the next thing I realize I am on
one of these guys in the middle of the
street pulling on the backpack.
He's stolen from another one of my
students.
Another one of my students has chased
down the other guy and thought how did
that happen and why is everything now so
loud and so colorful?
And I thought back immediately thought,
wow,
the entire experience that I just had
was somehow in black and white and was
without sound.
And so,
I mean,
it's an interesting long story that,
that I basically explored in this essay
by going into and doing a dive into the
literature on the nature of memory,
on the nature of sensory memory in
particular and what it is that we can
and cannot perceive in the moment,
what our brains take in,
why time seems to slow down.
So just to go back to our early
conversation about time,
why 10 time seems to slow down in
periods of intensity.
It's not that it time slows down,
but basically our frame rate increases
and not only our frame rate increases,
but the amount that we remember and you
know,
move into short term memory.
And then in this case into longterm
memory increases.
So this is,
this is one of the things that I've been
thinking about lately is sort of how,
how memory and the senses and in fact,
how all of us are a little bit of
synesthesia.
It's,
are experiencing our world in ways that,
that we don't usually have language for.
Not that it was the purpose of the
story,
but how did this all end?
It ended.
We got,
we got the stuff back,
and as soon as the student,
Jeremy and I gave Tracy these guys and
got the stuff back.
Then the police showed up,
then doppler it up from the end and the
whole were watching.
It was.
It was remarkable actually.
It was totally.
There was no one on this walk.
We'd send no one.
These two guys run up to US Magus
runoff.
We give chase and then the entire
neighborhood comes alive.
Suddenly there were hundreds of people
there,
like,
where were you guys?
There's some sort of study to be done on
that.
Well,
I'm sure they've done studies on that.
You know when people see the bad thing
happening,
but nobody calls the police and all that
kind of stuff.
Well listen,
it's been an absolute pleasure.
I'm so glad that we finally got to do
this in person and we will do it again.
You guys can follow heather on the
twitter.
She does tweet a decent amount,
but not a unhealthy addicted amount.
I would say it's at heather.
He hiding.